how you doing dustin
how are you thank you man i give you a
shout out bro
i listen i i don't do it for the shot
and i'm glad you hit a thousand man i'm
really really happy for you
thank you man all my fa all my fans all
my fans love you man
thank you yeah absolutely where are you
from by the way where
are you i'm at that what state are you
in i meant to ask you uh i'm from uh
donaldsonville georgia georgia ah
georgia fan okay yes sir
bulldogs huh yes sir yeah okay well
that's that's good i mean maybe you guys
have a good football team again at some
point
um but how you so
so let me ask you how long you've been
on youtube for uh i've been on youtube
i started in 2015. oh wow 2015 so you so
you've been doing this for a while huh
yes sir now okay so i i'm kind of
relatively new to the channel my buddy
jj stoner is actually the one that
introduced me to you
yes sir yeah so um
i was i was just a bunch of questions
obviously if you don't mind i mean i
don't know if i'm
interrupting your stream if you might
have asked some questions
well first off where are your friends
here who who's ashley and justin
hi guys how you doing justin um
i went to school with him okay he lived
down to the lake
where i'm at we both live in in the same
town
oh okay so you guys let me actually
subscribe
for me subscribe to her and
she comes up on on my panel and you know
give me a shout out and
you know hang out with me and stuff so
you guys
you guys are all you guys are just all
all good friends basically
yes sir wow that's cool um so
i guess okay so something else that's
kind of intrigued me about you
what what's up with the with the with
the skirts is are they more comfortable
or
i'm just curious well i kind of enjoy
wearing them
and they make me feel happy pretty and
enjoy life you know i kind of
they make me feel good well no no listen
it's just like my grandfather my
grandfather always said like yolo except
with black people and stuff
he was racist don't don't hold it
against him but so you wear skirts and
stuff so they're more comfortable i've
never done it
uh but i don't know denim
denim looks kind of uncomfortable again
no sir it's actually not it's actually
uh only thing different between denim
pants and denim skirt
you don't have that that rubbing in the
in the crotch area
okay so you're so you're it's basically
like rocking jeans without having to
worry about and look i live in florida
i understand the humidity and i get your
balls sticking to the side of your legs
and stuff and that's terrible
trust me i get it so it does help out a
bit um
so if it's just a skirt thing if you
don't mind me asking and please you
please don't feel comfortable you're not
are you have a girlfriend you have a
boyfriend
i got a girlfriend i'm a straight guy oh
cool i'm i'm straight as a hero hint kid
is my girlfriend
okay i go here on the chat with me
okay see i see her in the chat room okay
so you're so you are actually
so you're just a straight guy that
enjoys wearing a skirt for comfort
reasons it makes you feel it makes you
feel good
yeah it makes me feel good and makes me
feel happy
i mean what good why can't a guy can
rock a dick
a skirt just like a woman can rock
like me and shirts and men's shorts and
me and shirts i mean why we can't you
know i can't rock a denim skirt
why can't i go into a woman's bathroom
when i want to i mean who's to tell me
society is a mess
honestly if you ask me if you're
comfortable if you're comfortable going
in a woman's bathroom you go in a
woman's bathroom and that's it and if
they get angry it's on them
that's just a little free advice here i
mean i'm just trying i'm just trying to
help everybody else out here look you're
one state away from me man so i kind of
know
i kind of know how it is so you can see
you have your girlfriend um do you wear
your skirt out like when you go to
movies and stuff
i'm look i'm not making funny or really
not i'm actually very intrigued by this
because first time i've ever met a
straight dude that wears a skirt
well i wear them out of public okay
and i don't let nobody kind of tell me
different
you know i have people like i could hear
them
talk about me but i don't let it bother
me
because i'm gonna love me for who i am
fair enough you know i'm not gonna let
no nobody you know bring me down
to try to break my spirit and stuff like
that
um did you so let me ask you a question
um
is is street is streaming your full-time
job
well it could be
but i'm on disability because
because um i can't work because my feet
gives me too much problems and i have
learning disability
too because my mom overdosed me on drugs
jesus is all proud of her whoa whoa i'm
not
joking aside i'm really sorry when you
were a kid or something
is that what happened inside of her she
overdosed
three times already oh my god i'm really
serious man i'm sorry i didn't i wasn't
aware i honestly couldn't tell i had no
idea
actually the doctors was telling my dad
uh he he only got one chance two
three four it kept on going up and even
the doctor said well if he lives
he's gonna be a vegetable oh my god
do i look like a vegetable to you no no
you don't you don't look like a
vegetable you look like a
you're a chad man you you know you do
what you i saw your championship belt uh
are you wrestling your big wrestling guy
yeah
i am and a football guy and i'm also an
fsu fan too
oh no boo boo boo boo boo i'm a miami
fan um fans oh my really yeah yeah
you you know so look i'm sorry about
that i i didn't realize that
uh that and i mean so you're doing
pretty good all things
all things considered so you have issues
with your feet and
but but you live on your own i mean you
looks like you take care of yourself
right
yes yes sir i actually bought this
trailer for two thousand dollars
for my sister's gran did it well
see she sold it to me because
i've been wanting a place on my own see
i'm able to tell you this um i live
i live with my dad for 29 years okay
and only because because i've been
having so much
problem when i was growing up my dad
didn't really want to let me
live on my own chitchat because i wasn't
ready
he saw me when i was ready to leave and
and stuff like that he put it
put it where i could get my own trailer
i got my own trailer
but we actually i live where
i was i was growing up when i was a kid
my dad used to have a trailer
sitting where my trailer was sitting now
when i was a baby
right but we live we live on 15 acres
now
oh wow 15 acres that's awesome yeah man
you know look it looks like
it looks like you really you really do
enjoy doing this youtube stuff i mean
that's really good i mean i know you
you've done some unboxing stuff i've
seen you do that i've seen you cut your
wrestling promos who's your favorite
wrestler right now
oh roman reigns roman reigns ah
roman reigns not a big roman reigns fan
i used to be
i still am a john cena's fan that was
who i really liked in the early 2000s
when he was there and stuff
would you but how how old are you dustin
i'm
32 fixing to be 33
february 18th oh wow your birthday's
coming up so early happy early birthday
um thank you so much you were so you you
weren't into the attitude area big stone
cold fan maybe the rock
oh yeah i was a stone cold fan the rock
and the undertaker the undertaker he is
a legend
he's an icon and
there won't be another guy like him
ever that can lace his boots
yeah i know you're right i mean i saw
you cut your wrestling promos i mean if
it wasn't for your feet you could
probably even do wrestling stuff i mean
have you ever thought about
going into wrestling um when
yeah i was gonna like if i didn't have
no problems with me
i could have went to wrestling or i
could have went pro football
oh really yeah
you go ahead you know what position what
position would you have played
quarterback because i always love
quarterbacks hell yeah man yeah you got
to be the leader of the team
when i see you i see clearly you're a
natural leader i mean you know you're
running the stream and you're doing your
thing
so i mean big props to you for that um
do you uh what what is it you do like i
mean i know because now you can't do a
lot of stuff but what is it you do for
fun like
do you get out the places or uh well i
got
three german shepherds nice
i play with them watch movies and play
my video games
on video games
call of duty modern warfare warzone
what do you play on xbox ps4 pc
ps4 ps4 your ps4 i got ps4 i got an xbox
two i play the call of duty on this i do
too
i was in xbox and then when i started my
youtube
and i wanted to get into gaming and the
ps4 was the only console
i can live stream and it work
but i wish xbox can wake the hell up
and do the same thing right through the
consoles
instead of doing this other stuff where
you can
you know live stream your games
right no no i i get you so so you're
doing gaming you're doing boxing videos
i see you cut your promos
and you hit a thousand man it looks like
you're doing good i am i'm very
i'm very happy that i'm very happy that
we could help in a little way i mean now
that you needed my help it looks like
you were on your way there
uh now let me ask let me ask you a
question
so i mean i've seen you do your i've
seen you do your walks with your skirts
i saw you were like i think it was a
black leather one am i correct
what what do you play any songs
specifically when you do those the
modeling of the skirts like maybe zz top
she's got legs or
no not because if i do that
i get a copyright oh you know what man
very smart so let me let me help you out
here
so what you do is when you want to play
songs that you like
play look for uh look for like covers
like search for zz top
she's got legs cover and that
that won't give you a copyright are you
wearing a skirt now if you don't mind me
asking
uh yes sir i am oh what kind the denim
one
yeah the denim is the long one my
favorite is the long one i don't know
why
but i enjoy the long ones so
you enjoy them you enjoy those long ones
you want to feel all snug you want to
feel all snugged up
yes sir how long you been dating your
girl for
um we've been dating for about about
so i could say about four years four
years are we looking at marriage at some
point or
uh right now she's in a rehab hospital
because she has a seizure
and she's trying to get out i'm sorry
she's a really good person though
he kid that's her youtube name yeah yeah
she don't make videos but she
support other people and stuff
she's really yeah she's really
it was good no no i'm saying she seems
very supportive
oh yeah she's really she's really
supportive over me
and protected over me that's amazing how
old is she's
right she around your age uh she's
a little older
so you so you so you like the more you
like that's okay like in the more mature
dignified ladies that's cool
yes sir okay let me ask you a question i
saw that you had a deer on your wall
like a mounted deer does it have a name
oh no sir all right we gotta name the
deer come on we're a youtuber now
we gotta name that deer come on let's
come on chad let's help him out let's
give
i would love to give that dear a name
you need like remember
you're you're older remember pee-wee's
play house um
yes sir okay yeah everything talk did
you get dear we need a name for that
dear i don't know what it's gonna be yet
but we
need a name for that deer what about
what about
what about head off the deer right off
the deer
yeah he's a deer i mean you know dusty
dusty
name out off the deer i
yeah nice my dad you know how my dad
killed it
he wanted to guess bare hands with his
bare hands
he killed it with a knife he cut the
throat so wait wait
he's jumping here
like rambo he came in like rambo and
just took him out
yeah that's [ __ ] awesome
and i know you're also a wwe you're the
champion right now i saw you cut your
promo video
um i'm gonna i'm look i'm accepting your
challenge okay
you name the place you name the time i
want that belt
all right do you hear me in a cage match
all right we'll do a cage match no dq
rules
we'll do it you name the place you name
the time you could wear your skirt
i'll wear my pants and we'll just do it
i mean i think it'll be good i don't
wrestle it in the skirt
it's too hard rushing on the screen wait
a second hold on hold on
that would be gonna be it's gonna be for
the title i ain't wearing no skirt
because
if it [ __ ] me up and made me lose
uh i'm gonna be wearing whatever i wanna
wear
what if it makes you know what if it
makes you win what if you're a little
more loose like think about it you're
more loose
you're kicking around a little bit i'm
just saying you might be right pull it
up
yeah well you can pull up the skirt you
can do the ritchie on me you know the
butt thing yo hey
you know whatever what you need to do
but yeah but i'm just saying
i mean you know you you call that
challenger
yeah somebody somebody said beer
beef says shirt versus skirt
shirt versus skirt i really like that
i'll tell you what man
i wear speedo you wear a skirt let's see
who's the best
where's
so you have the spinner one and the new
one yeah
well the universe i got the red version
not the blue version
red one right right right right i'll
tell you what you put up your title up
against my big gold belt the old wcw one
what do you say does that seem fair
unified champion we'll do a unified
championship and special guest referee
add off the deer
i really think that we could do this i
think that we could book this and we'll
give all the money to charity
all the money to charity yeah we'll give
all the money to charity i mean there's
a bunch of different charities
um there's a charity i give to that's
called the whoops of baby abortion
clinic
it is it is and it just you know helps
out mothers that are having a tough time
i think that's not a bad one we could
raise the money and we'll take care of
it i really really think we could do it
um and uh and i got to say man i lo i i
love your southern accent there's
something about a southern accent that's
great for wrestling
yeah there is they're really you got to
watch out though
because rko out of nowhere you're done
yeah
ho ho you're going to try to rko me my
friend first off randy orton will sue
you you got to come up with your own
finisher
you know uh listen you nee you need your
own
we're going to help you out here so
what's going to be your wrestling name
it can't be dustin because dustin
you gotta come up with the wrestling
name so what would be a coordinator
the tornado okay so so the tournament so
i don't know what don't you think like
hurricane helms will be upset at that
but i get it so like
so you're gonna be the tornado uh so
it'll it'll be like um
atlanta georgia weighing 245 pounds
six foot tall tornado
and then we'll just we'll have music for
you so like i have a song for you tell
me what you think
tell me what you think about this song
as your uh
somebody wants to come up here what
about this song
[Music]
we got some people in the chat room so i
see some of my daily people here hanging
out
it's pretty cool yeah that's pretty cool
yeah
how about how about this how about me
and you
come together and take the raw tag team
titles
i mean look we can we could probably go
for the raw tag team titles but be
careful because we might
pull sean michael you're gonna kick me
through the barbershop window
i don't know i don't why don't you like
my friends
oh okay yeah it's true sean was really
bad
sean was actually really bad with his
friends in backstage wasn't it
wrestling game on my ps4 it's called wwe
2k
20. oh 2k20 all right yeah all right why
don't we we'll play some wrestling man
let's do it
all right i'll give you my i'll i'll
i'll dm you my
uh my info uh so we could play well i'll
tell you what dustin i'm doing well so
here's what i want to do for you
and you're going to tell me and i would
tell me i'm flying i'm gonna get you a
skirt of your choice okay on me this is
on me
to show you that i really do want i
really want to make sure you do well
i want you to have one you name the type
of skirt you want you tell me the size
send me the link
and i will get it over to you asap i
mean that i'm being
you you pick your skirt and i got it
it's on me
okay all right man i appreciate that
yeah man sure why not i mean who cares i
mean
i listen all i want is i want you to
succeed there's a lot of you
you put in the work and you know you you
rise and grind you you put it out there
and i want to make sure
that when you do it so you let me know
what kind of skirt here's the question
that i that i do have for you when you
wear the skirt because i just question
i have no idea um when you
when you wear a skirt do you wear
women's underwear you still wear men's
underwear
um i wear
man's underwear oh okay well those are
those are kind of cute
those are tiny whities though you're
rocking them you're rocking them all
right that was just curious because i
know you do the skirt but
a skirt but you're still going to wear
men underwear you're not going to wear a
small i thought it would be
uncomfortable i mean i don't know i've
never worn one but i was talking
don would be uncomfortable although you
should try it let me know what you think
um any particular screwdriver
how about something lacy how about a
lazy skirt
i got one like look dustin's a thousand
subs now he's he's a big timer dustin's
a big timer to youtube now with a
thousand
he's the guy he's he's the guy he's got
a thousand he's he's the top
he's you know what i will call you roman
reigns dustin you're the top dog
it's your yard a big dog a big
dog that's right yeah
that's a good bark actually it's a
better park than me that's pretty good
really yeah yeah it's a good bark man
hey
let me ask you a question because just
because i know especially because you're
from this mouth
what is what does your family think
about you wearing skirts are they okay
with it oh my dad's cool with it
that's pretty easy yeah he i thought he
was going to throw me out
and never talk to me again but he kind
of
he he's accepts it but he don't
understand
it right so he accept do you have a
sister or brother or anything or
i have two sisters what do they think
about it
uh they're okay with it now now
yeah they're okay with you you had
issues with it before huh
well they didn't like what i was doing
they didn't like
why why was that why didn't they like
what you were doing on youtube you
didn't do anything bad on youtube
uh because um
it's because it's supposed to be for
women only
youtubers women are you mean skirts
the skirts oh i see okay i misunderstood
okay so
the skirts are for women only well what
about scottish people they wear kilts
those are skirts
yeah but they're kind of like a manly
top
skirt oh a manly skirt yeah i get that
there's manly skirts and there's girly
skirts i don't know what kids
because i told him the story what
happened
oh geez okay wait you spent your
stimulus check on skirts
well no no no yeah that's a lot dude
that's a lot of money to spend on skirts
i don't spend that much on pants
where did we get the 1400 that biden's
spending out
buying's gonna send you 14 are you gonna
hey dustin maybe start investing your
money man i don't know look at the stock
market what do you think about maybe
putting money in here that money to put
fix up my trailer
yeah that's fine except for your trade
i'm how many skirts does nine hundred
dollars buy you
okay one two
about 10 or 15
how many skirts do you have total
uh i really don't know
i will show you the
are those
dustin has more clothes than you've had
yeah that's a lot of skirts man
do you wear them all do you rotate them
because it seems like you wear your
denim skirt a lot
yeah i can i kind of rotate them
hey let me ask you a question the
championship you buy that dude
do what your championship belts did you
buy them
yes sir i did how much were they
i'm just curious
the um the intercontinental in the
united states was
150 a piece
and the wwe title and
the you the universal was 250
and the the replica
of the john cena spinner championship
was 250. was that stimulus money too
no i bought them a while back uh
you bought that with your social
security money right you
always get always always uh you know
allow myself to have a hundred dollars
for spending money the rest of it goes
to limit spence
yeah it's it's you know i get it i mean
look it's it's okay
it's uh it's an investment um
so so i see you have championship rings
or those is that is that
an alabama championship bring you
wearing no
it's my uh it's my class ring ah do you
have any california
yeah i got two and got one georgia
georgia
oh wow okay so you're you're walking
that's you know you're you're a big
spender man
you're like you're like the million
dollar man you're out there buying
skirts
and and buying rings all right yeah cool
let me know where you live and i'm gonna
i'm gonna get it for you and then you
gotta you gotta do an unboxing video for
me when you get it
oh yeah i will i'll definitely that
would be great man that would be great
and then
maybe one day we can have you on my show
if you if you get up you can't will you
be up at
what time do you normally get up in the
morning i get up around about
sometimes i get up around about 10
and sometimes i get up early
and sometimes i get up around about 12
because
a lot of times i have trouble sleeping
why is that
because i i really don't know i just
i guess because my
my you know sleeping times kind of
messed up you know
oh yeah you're sitting up you're staying
up too late you're staying up too late
playing games man you gotta you gotta
you gotta fix your your uh your sleeping
pattern
yes sir yeah do you have nightmares or
do you have nightmares
um well sometimes i do
but sometimes i have good dreams
what's the last good dream you had
one where um i was
like in a like a single eye mobile home
but it had like an extension onto it
just the living room part
okay wow and now
go ahead and i was
it had like about four windows on the
back end and four windows
on the end and the door and the
fireplace
was like right in the corner
i got to hop off here man i just wanted
to say congratulations on a thousand all
right
all right hey everybody oh thank you
after you get up i'm glad i've seen you
the uh
my address and all that look
hell yeah man and you know um let me let
me see here
um and you let me ask you a question can
you hear this
if i play this can you hear this uh
give me one second give me one second
all right can you can you hear this
audio coming from my computer
hello guys hello guys hi rudy how are
you
good yeah i can hear it
hey rudy i think oh this is my entry
this is
[Music]
thanks man i think i like it too
[Music]
yeah dance do you guys dance i dance do
you guys dance at all
i i do sometimes no
thank you my husband's over here dancing
in the chair now
yeah guys come on everybody let's do it
let's do it
i have 28 reviews
[Music]
all right look guys thank you so much i
wanted to say uh
i wanted to say thank you for having me
on i appreciate it keep doing you're
welcome man
and i appreciate
[Music]
congratulations on a thousand my friend
uh hopefully a thousand
more very soon and maybe i'll hop on
again i'm gonna get that skirt out to
you all right brother
bye brother all right hey you guys have
a wonderful day wave okay